the use of force against george floyd
was uncalled for and totally unnecessary
damning testimony from a top officer on
derek shovin's actions
in keeping his knee on george floyd's
neck
have you ever in all the years you've
been working for the minneapolis police
department
uh been trained to kneel on the neck of
someone who is handcuffed behind their
back in a prone position
no i haven't is that if that were done
would that be considered
force absolutely what
level of force might that be that would
be the top tier
the deadlift force why because of
the fact that um if if your knee is on a
person's neck
that can kill him as head of homicide
lieutenant zimmerman was deployed to the
scene after it emerged
george floyd had died the court had
previously heard
when paramedics arrived one believed
george floyd was already dead
and how derek shovin stayed on top of
him when the medic was trying to check
for a pulse
now critical evidence from a senior
officer
who says keeping a suspect in this
position is against police protocol
once you secure or handcuff a person
you need to get them out of the prone
position as soon as possible
because it restricts their breathing
after an intense and emotional week in
court
the parting evidence for the jury from
one of his own colleagues
presents a challenge for derek chovin's
defense
that he was simply doing what he'd been
trained to do
sally lockwood sky news minneapolis